[Musique]
nous disons que je veux que tu sois mon vice-président Je te veux
tu es mon préjugé bien George chéri Je suis
PDG d'une grande entreprise et j'ai été
secrétaire à la Défense et j'ai été
chef de cabinet de la Maison Blanche  la vice-
présidence est un travail essentiellement symbolique,
mais si nous parvenons à une compréhension différente,
je peux gérer les tâches les plus
banales supervisant la bureaucratie,
l'énergie militaire
et la politique étrangère ouais, j'aime
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Oh,
quand vous avez du pouvoir, les gens essaieront toujours
pour te le prendre toujours
es-tu encore plus impitoyable qu'avant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc nous allons faire ce truc quoi
qu'il arrive